so Richard Dawkins Richard Dawkins is uh
one of the most influential uh atheists
in the world uh he's I think he's in his
probably early 70s at this point I I've
interviewed him about five years ago at
the uh 92nd Street Y in New York City
um he has been a profoundly impactful
thinker on the world anti-religion
pro-secularism but really pro-atheism
and he's been radical it's not just he's
been pro-atheism he's been radically
against religion
the woke have tried to destroy him many
times and suddenly in his 70s now he is
finally coming around to something that
I think many uh many of us see whether
we are devoutly religious or not uh take
a look at a portion of this interview he
did just a few days ago
the question is
is a
purely empirically practically in terms
of the success of our societies the
peace and prosperity of the world
is conventional religion
or what appears to be its successor
which are new slightly strange
ideologies that don't formally belong in
the religious category but as you say
have religious aspects which one was
will be proven to be more successful for
the flourishing of the species I guess
we still don't know but it oh Early
times are that this new kind of religion
which thinks it's secular has some quite
major problems attached to it well if
you care about flourishing of the
species yes but I care about truth
you don't care about the flourishing
well I do care about it as a human being
but more more deeply I care about truth
so if your sense of Truth would lead to
the annihilation of these no I mean
would you be content I would not be
content of that and I would and because
I'm pretty sure it wouldn't it wouldn't
happen I mean I think I think that the
truth actually is a genuine value I mean
I I I
believe that a true scientific outlook
on the on the world would actually be
best for the flourishing of humankind
okay now I get it he's a little muddled
there right because he thinks that
somehow flourishing of the species and
what he decided is truth which is that
there's no God that them somehow that
these things are at odds with each other
but it's a real concession by him maybe
it was a little bit by accident where
he's saying that religion if you care
about the flourishing of the species is
a net positive for society now again
he's still for whatever reason thinks
that that's at odds uh with being a
Believer even though everyone ends up
believing in something right like even
for the phase that I went through as an
atheist you end up believing in
something one way or another there's
something that is driving you whether
you sort of know it or not Jordan
Peterson and Sam Harris got into this
many times and Jordan would repeatedly
say sam you know you in essence you
believe in something you're laying out
what you believe to be true to me you
just don't believe that you believe in
it something to that effect right now
interestingly Jordan has had some
conversations over the years with
Richard Dawkins he saw that clip he
wrote something interesting here and
then I want to show you a clip from
Jordan he said I warned you Richard
Dawkins about what would happen in the
aftermath of the enforced death of
judeo-christian tradition you thought
people would become more rational and
that I was drunk on symbols so they had
talked this out and that's the line that
Dawkins used on Jordan that Jordan was
drunk on symbols because he was pushing
belief he was pushing the important the
importance of these religious stories
foreign
[Music]